Nice to meet you, my name is Cliff hastings.
Thank you for your introduction and online talk
.
How is Matty or Online bringing the world's ultimate computing system to the cloud
today?  I
will tell you about whether you can use interactive notebooks directly in a web browser
. With Majika Online, you can use Mathematica without installing anything from any computer as long as you have an internet connection
.
We
will also talk about how you can share your volume or online documentation with others, including those who do not have an online license. This
is
a very convenient and easy way to publish your documentation to colleagues, students, collaborators, etc.
I
'll also touch on how to use the cloud to the end of the desktop location.
Think about the benefits of having both desktop and online licenses
. How to use Mati or Online on mobile devices like ipad.
Finally, I will talk about mathematica online licensing options on an individual or organizational scale
.
First, open a web browser or
enter your account information on the online login screen.
When launched, you'll see a welcome
screen from which you
can create new notebooks, access resources to get started with the product,
and browse files stored in your wolfram cloud account through a file browser
.  Or if you have an online account, you should have some cloud storage allocated to store your notebooks and related files
.
You can also buy additional storage if you want.
Then click Play and new document and
drop down.  Select a notebook from the menu to create a new notebook.
A new tab for Dr. Notebook Documents will open. Close the sidebar to free up space before you start.
Let's spread
it out If you've used Maticar more and
more, you'll be familiar with this part of his notebook document. The
horizontal bar is marked with a +. This is where you write your input.
Shows several menu items The
File menu has file duplication and download operations
on the keyboard, and there is also a link to open his manuscript notebook. The
format menu changes the style color size of the Cellstar rear font.
A nice insert menu
can also be useful for pasting special characters such as his symbols and operators. I
'll talk more about the share menu later.
It is an
insertion assistant that can be marked with a + to indicate that
it is ready to be created. Click here to open the menu and select the input type.
For example, select other style of text and select a
title from the drop-down menu.
You can enter text like Muddy or Online and add content here. Bass Matty on your
desktop Just like he does, you can use your mouse to click above or below an existing cell
to enter new input.  You can also
use the arrow keys on your keyboard
to move through the cells and between the cells. The
cursor is at the bottom of the notebook so you can
click the Insert Assistant icon again and this time it's free.  Select form input
This will give you an orange integration
You can give commands in simple English like plot sign x in this cell
Press shift and enter keys on your keyboard when you're done
mathematica Tells the online to evaluate the input and return the result. The
result will be returned immediately. In the
background, the volume or online understands that it was instructed to draw a 3x
plot and returns the x plot to the subject.  Wait more and
more online will also determine the plot range of the function etc.
If you use free-form input, it is the driving force of waiting and other wolfram products.
No wolfram language knowledge anyone can quickly start using Magica Online
Free-form input can also be used to search for information
number of turkey Questions like Sincherkey will also give results
Wait more and more online understands the difference between turkey turkey and turkey meaning country Turkey and
uses that information to look up relevant data
and return answers
Oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh you can also use the wolfram language directly  This is
also the default type when you start typing to create a new one with the first option when you click the Insert Assistant,
which opens a pop-up window when you start typing a command in the wolfram language, for example pl.  The
possible command names are listed.
Select one and click the double down chevron icon to
see templates showing different ways to use this command. In
this case, select the first template for the plot command
3x  Type the rest of the information needed to plot from 0 to 10 on the
desktop and like him you can use the tab key to
move to the next
placeholder.  It is also supported. You
can use free-form input to instruct to plot the sign x times cos y, and
once you have created a
3d plot, you can click and drag the plot to rotate it interactively using the manipulate command.
You can also hit the model
3x + 3rd place f times xe
x is from 0 to 4 losses
f is from 1 to 5 Let's plot and operate
this slider bar to change the value of f  Let's see what happens to this plot.
If you add a different parameter, for example, make a
prod style arrow color and make the
arrow using a hyphen and a big symbol.
In this case it has a colors lector that changes the appearance of the plot
.  You can delete, copy and paste to move it back
, and the contents of the cell can be hidden or displayed by double-clicking the cell bracket of the cell
, so the example with the manipulator created earlier
If you want to show only the result without showing the code, you can hide the code.
Next, create a new file and open the parentheses using free-form input.
The result will include some type
settings.
Select the output bracket, click the gear icon and now
select the Barts 2 Traditional Form to convert it to the format used in the textbook.
You can also give it a name now that you have a
document The document itself is already stored in my wolfram cloud account
This work is done automatically in the background You
don't have to do it consciously
But when you want to name the document, click the icon that appears at the top of the screen,
type a name like My First Notebook, and click the checkmark
when you're done. If you want to open this file, open the
sidebar.  You can open it and click Home to find it in the list of files stored in your cloud account
. If you want to share a file with someone on your desktop,
it's normal to send it to the other person, such as by
email.  The other party can be rolled up or opened with a
cdf player cdf player is a free browsing software that can be downloaded from our website.
If you are online, sharing documents is much easier.
Share at the top of your notebook.
Click this to display a menu that lists how to share a notebook.
Sharing methods include private documents and public web pages
.
Sharing a notebook as a private document will bring up who in this document.
You can choose if you can access it When you select a
private document a pop-up window will appear and
this file can only be accessed by my collaborator viewer
You will see a message that it is private A
collaborator is someone who can see and edit the file.
To be a collaborator
, you must have access to a volume or online registered by yourself or your institution.  No
viewer is someone who can see and interact with the file.
You can't edit the file. The
viewer doesn't need an email or online license, but
you need to create a free account to see the shared file.
Adding a collaborator or viewer is very easy, just select the appropriate option
and enter your email address.
For example, if you want to share this notebook with multiple collaborators
, separate your email addresses here with a comma.  Enter When you
add a collaborator to a file,
an email will be sent to the collaborator notifying you that the file will be
accessible. You can also add a personal message to this email,
as well as add a viewer.
You can add as many collaborators as you like, but as I said earlier
, they must have their own volume or online registration
. You can also add multiple viewers.  However, there is a limit on the number of people
depending on the account. If you need an additional viewer, you can upgrade the account to increase the number of people
.  All you need to be online is a browser so you can view shared content on
mobile devices like ipad. Now switch to ipad.
You can open files in your cloud account from here using your device's touch
screen.  You can interact with files, you can
scroll, evaluate, remove,
and interact with content like the model of the manipulator,
more and more online from a standard computer.  Using is more
and more the same as using his desktop license in many ways,
but if you access more and more Matty or online from your mobile device,  There are some functions that cannot be used.
Functions and options for accessing Basmati or online will be further developed in the
future.
So far, we have talked about the basics of how to communicate and share files with Marty or online
.
So what if you have a notebook that you have created with a desktop license and stored on your desktop and
you don't want to roll it up or create it from scratch online again? How
many ways to move files from your hard disk to the cloud?
There is an upload icon in the Marty or online sidebar that
you can use to open a dialog and select the file you want to upload to your cloud account
.
This is one way to move the file to the cloud
.  I'll try uploading a file called Zample Notebook
You can open it from the sidebar browser You can do the same if you have more and more Matty points on your desktop more and more from Matty Day
Waiting for your desktop  Switch to Crab Select Save to wolfram cloud from the File menu
This will open a window
to save the file or create a new folder to save the file This
will move the file every 9 times you meet  It's another very convenient way.
There are other features that can help you move between platforms,
for example, go back online and open the file you just uploaded
. The icon at the top points to the computer display.
Click this to download the file from the cloud to your local hard disk,
which will open in the desktop's wait-and-see feature
This file
has all the features such as interactive tea provided by the desktop front end.
It's very easy to move between platforms, upload to a cloud account,
or download to a local machine, so
do you need both Mati and Maji or online on your desktop?
However
, I would like to answer that it can be used
.  It's very convenient to be able to store files in the loudspeaker and access and back up from anywhere
.
Did you ever do something that couldn't be installed without
? Wait or use online will completely solve this problem and you
can share online files with just a few button clicks on your
project.  It's never been easier to collaborate with others or get your colleagues and students to access your
files, especially on mobile devices.
It makes it very easy to view the based content on tablets, smartphones, etc.
This is very valuable,
but the desktop is more and more parallel computing using local machines and
the front-end interface provided by the desktop.  It's still worth a lot of validation, such as taking advantage of all the benefits
. For example, if
you use a plate object in the middle of a desktop, the
object will react instantly because all the calculations are done on your
machine.  There is no delay between adjustments and results such as plots There are
also additional menus and options like input rainbow two-dimensional type settings and point & click palettes on the
tablet waiting and of course waiting on the desktop machine  If you have installed, you
don't need to connect to your internet
unless you want to use internet-specific features like the natural input I showed you earlier.  I
've done a workflow to save and share more and more Matty or online.
Even if you need to wait and don't have the machine you normally use, you can
log in to your account and try again to continue working with your colleagues.  You can share the file
How
much can you access the file using your mobile device
Wait more and there are several options for how to buy online
Personally wait or buy online from our website  You already have
For those who have his desktop license
and want to go online, or
who haven't used the wolfram product before and want to wait and wait for the desktop again or both online.
For desktops, we recommend that you purchase his license with Premier Services +
, which
offers both licenses as well as benefits such as free upgrades and
priority access to technical support.
If your institution already owns a site license and you want to wait
and add online, there is an easy option for that.
The brief introduction is over.
Did you understand that the integration of online functions and desktops will make your workflow even more convenient?
If you would like pricing information, the name and location of your institution.
If you have mathematica for desktop, please include the
license number and
cliff h and wolfram. Please send us an e-mail.
Thank you for joining us today
and we look forward to seeing your work made online.